so uh Matt Walsh tweeted earlier that uh
we're winning we're winning and that all
the left has left is censorship I
believe he is correct he's correct in
this post from glad it says lgbtq
celebrities and allies call an Instagram
Facebook YouTube Tick Tock and Twitter
to stop the flow of anti-trans hate and
malicious disinformation about trans
Health Care true allies do not profit
from anti-lgbtq hate y'all are losing
it's not gonna happen
sorry the fact that Google just canceled
a pride event shows your CL your cries
are falling on deaf ears
so I'm not going to read the letter
because it's stupid but they're
basically like anybody who says we're
wrong is actually hateful that's what
they've been they've been saying that
forever look at all these people but
it's been there like one thing Alan
oh he's a great actor man well
foreign
Amy Schumer will we have to do it we
have to do it if Amy schumerous I I just
don't think that there's any way around
it at this point boys all right who else
we got here Billy Eisner who's that oh
Billy eckner he just did the uh the
rom-com the gay rom-com bombed nobody
wanted to watch
and and I'll say this too about his
movie Bros just simply put yeah if you
make a movie whose Target demographic is
point zero four percent of the
population don't be surprised when it
sells tickets to only point zero four
percent of the population actually do be
surprised and call everyone a homophobe
that's what he did didn't he that's
right well I don't know if he actually
did it but but it bombed and they were
like it's not fair something was wrong
they're they're they it should work
Dylan Mulvaney's on there believe it or
not oh
it's a cult Judd Apatow yeah the thing
is like I don't think it's possible for
any of these names to disappoint me you
know
she's the voice of Katara in uh Avatar
well what are they what was the letter I
don't want to really want to read
through all of it basically saying they
want us banned for oh for for transfer
for not supporting good child sex
changes
look Healthcare they call it Healthcare
in the letter I understand the position
not everyone agrees that cutting young
children uh to to sever parts of them is
necessarily Health Care they they they
appeal to Authority and say well the you
know AMA says so but my my point the
whole time which has not been refuted by
a single person other than your science
is not real science even though it is is
that you have several studies showing
desistance without intervention is over
60 percent that study needs well also
the Netherlands started doing this more
than one it's multiple studies yeah and
another one started doing this in 1990
basically before I mean not just
basically but before any other country
and they've found that the suicide rate
doesn't decrease so I mean either the
left has to say that Europe's medical
system and particularly the Netherlands
medical system Nordic Europe's medical
system got it wrong and America's evil
grub Capital system got it right or
here's my point for these people if
let's use the lowest possible
interpretation of desistance studies 60
if 60 of kids who are dysphoric receive
no intervention and then go on to lead
normal lives
why give them intervention if there is a
60 chance you will subject them to
something which has a high rate of
suicidality
it literally makes no sense the the odds
are in are are leaning towards let the
kid grow up yeah go at the very least go
through uh 14 or 15 years old should be
the minimum before they even consider
doing any kind of social whatever
because if a child is this fork and you
do literally nothing it's actually
upwards of 98 of kids desist they don't
de-transition I'm saying if they never
receive intervention in any way they go
on to lead normal lives and not only
that but these numbers are from before
we saw the massive spike in trans
identifying youth so this was before
every other kid started calling
themselves non-binary which means now
the desistance rate is almost certainly
going to be much much higher the funny
thing is like I guarantee you not a
single one of these individuals knows
anything about this but of course they
don't know anything about anything right
about the assistance Dylan Mulvaney
yeah he did that JoJo rabbit movie Wanda
Sykes
Rosario Dawson is surprising I thought
it wasn't Luke doesn't Luke know Rosary
she she was with Cory Booker for a while
Senator Cory Booker like dating or yeah
dating well you know there you go there
you go that'll do it yeah that's a cult
man we got to use if you want to get
through to people like this you should
use in my my opinion Patrick Stewart's
smaller words so how dare you Captain
Picard decisions I think just blanket
confuses people that aren't really
highly intelligent if they hear
desistence they're like they don't know
what that means
um dysphoric that word's too much for
people they don't really so if we could
you can use like simple language like
most of the kids that like child sex
don't get child sex changes turn out to
be not you know they turn out to be okay
kind of thing yeah
um that's a that's good kind of well I
used to get sick what they're doing to
the kids agreed I think uh Chloe Cole
she makes a really compelling case as to
why you should not allow children to do
this you know she went through the
transition process when she was 16 and
regretted it by the time she turned 18
but by by then it was already too late
for her now she has uh she won't be able
to have children and a lot of these
different complications and she speaks
out so adamantly about how this is wrong
and children shouldn't do it uh and you
know we need to take action probably at
a federal level to ban puberty blockers
uh ban these testosterone for dysphoria
for children
um and also we just need to ban the
surgeries and the procedures it should
not happen in our country uh it's it's
wrong and I feel like every single
politician uh you know that's in the
senate or in Congress if a Muslim
country for example was mutilating the
genitalia of the youth every single
member would send sign a resolution
saying it's disgusting it's barbaric and
it's wrong meanwhile here in our country
they're like oh this is so wonderful and
so
um you know I remember about four or
five years ago there was a case in
Minnesota where a Muslim doctor was
illegally mutilating the genitalia of
right of young girls and everybody's
outraged about that but if you do it in
the name of oh the parents wanted it
yeah parents brought the little girl the
little girl agreed and the doctor
performed the surgery it's wrong but but
the left is in favor of parental rights
as they describe it
it's so wrong but they were all outraged
about that case why do you care so much
because I want to have children one day
and I don't want to have them grow up
and thinking that they're the wrong
gender because they're not and uh we
can't let this happen amen well I mean
it's it's this refrain we hear from them
all the time whenever you point out
anything disgusting is happening why do
you care so much why do you even know
that that's happening it's like I mean
you can literally make that argument
about any horrible thing that's
happening in the world
um the only way to win the argument
shame is is to make sure nobody can have
it is to make sure that nobody can have
the artist nobody can care nobody can
have the argument
what they're saying is yeah oh yeah yes
it is it is better that no one talk
about it yeah because if they do the
results all go in the same direction
exactly people clearly people will see
that this is all made up nonsense then
again you wonder how much of this look
this is Hollywood all right how much of
it is these people going I really care
about this cause and how much is it uh
Excuse me yes this is your manager
calling you're going to sign this it's
going to look really great for publicity
all right and yes no we're putting your
name on it okay gotcha boom what does it
say ah it doesn't matter it's going to
look good it's going to make you look
good you're gonna be star darling
I think I uh I think I have an example
for you from today yeah take a look at
this from page six non-drinker Blake
Lively accused of cash grab as she
launches the alcohol brand I saw the
story earlier everyone's like yo she
talks about how she doesn't drink and
she's selling booze what what do you
what did you expect yeah like let me
tell you I wake up in the morning and I
drink Casper coffee I thought you're
gonna say you wake up and drink booze I
was like damn no I drink coffee like we
we Blended our own coffee it is
delicious I like drinking it I would
like you to buy it
she does not actually want to drink she
wants you to drink this is what these
celebrities do like I got no beef on her
launching a product she doesn't have to
be a drinker to sell booze I'm just
saying don't be surprised when they come
out to you and they're like for just 10
cents you can save a pet in need and
then as soon as the camera raps they
walk over and she's like you know
throwing the bringing the cats to the
youth for euthanasia or whatever like
they don't care yeah exactly exactly I
mean it's all superficial they're all
just trying to promote something so that
they can profit themselves obviously in
this instance they're promoting
something which is unbelievably barbaric
disgusting horrible something that
people in a civilized society would not
support and yet here we are because we
are increasingly less civil with each
passing day but ultimately I agree They
Don't Really targeted they don't know
about it they don't know targeted
misgendering
and dead naming of trans and non-binary
people
they're saying that's got to be stopped
yeah like dude
you cannot tell me what I can or cannot
call you
if you want to have an argument about
harassment
there's a block button as a mute button
but I can understand I can understand
there is a line in harassment legally
and criminally speaking if you go out in
public and you're showing somebody's
house or their place of work and you're
insulting them and screaming at them in
demeaning ways the police are going to
say you are now officially harassing
this person you have to stop it of
course or otherwise you will be
criminally charged I agree with that as
it pertains to social media but if it is
an open public conversation where I in
my space my Twitter account I say I
think Ian's name is Ian and he's a guy
and I'm going to keep saying it that's
not harassment I'm expressing an opinion
on a public figure what if someone
chases you down the street and says hey
I'm gonna gay bash you
that's a crime do you think it happened
though it literally it obviously didn't
happen
story is really really sad and and and
you know being one of the signatories on
this it shows you the depravity of these
people yeah I will I will tell you the
story I I feel
there's a lot of people
who will look at say like uh Dylan
Mulvaney and then
the feeling they get from seeing someone
make a mockery of women they then
project onto all trans people and I
think it's really important that when
you think about someone like Elliot page
you should be having sadness in your
heart sympathy and empathy for this
individual who is seriously abused in
Hollywood and became depressed was
self-harming was hearing voices all this
is all from the Elliot page LA Times
like like Memoir story
this is a person who is in deep need of
help
and the problem is I don't I don't I
don't the people who there's no one
there to help these individuals because
you'll either get conservatives being
condescending and rude most of the time
to any of any of these people and then
what happens to someone like Ellie page
can only go to the left and what does
the left do encourages self-harm yeah so
that's why I'm like when we were talking
earlier about like Gizmodo I'm like I'll
hire him yeah like the only only way you
get people to stop doing bad things is
give them an opportunity to do good
things yeah I mean there has to be road
to repentance yeah absolutely turn it
around yeah I think that
um
people were
showing some compassion towards uh I
guess I don't see compassion but most
people have always been against the
trans movement and period uh but people
didn't have as much hatred in their
hearts towards them until they started
coming for the kids
and sell this until they started
promoting hey young you know
five-year-old you can transition genders
and we are here for you and that didn't
I feel like that has escalated so
quickly and it's only a couple years old
this movement and maybe it's been going
on behind the scenes a little bit longer
but like it's becoming mainstream the
last couple of years and it's turning
people that were like you know what uh I
don't really care what you do as an
adult to uh like I'm against it
altogether the San Francisco Boys Choir
they made a song um we'll convert their
children men's course and it was I think
an example of when someone gets a hold
of a large amount of power and then
misuses it like they had the trans
Community the trans movement was going
strong when that came out it was like
finally for the first time reality they
have a voice they're talking about it in
public it's mainstream conversation and
then they go and do something like that
and piss off Untold it was not the trans
Community it was like some gay men small
group yeah yeah and it was like 50 guys
so what are they saying they're going to
come gay men are going to come for your
kids like what and they tell what they
thinking exactly in the song that they
want to do they want to they want to
take your kids and bring them to hang
out with with strangers they want to
expose them to things parents trying to
protect them against I mean yeah it's
it's it's it's it's evil those guys
don't speak for all gay people obviously
but man what an abuse what a mistake
what a fumble when you have that kind of
opportunity to create a conversation and
it's I I don't think it was a mistake on
their part I think they knew exactly
what they were saying and doing I think
they knew exactly what they were saying
and doing I think what you were saying
it is evil and um you know president
Trump he's like I don't like the word
woke
well because what's happening in our
country it's not just well it's sick and
it's evil what they're doing to or to
our kids isn't woke it is sick and it is
evil and is demonic and it needs to be
called that and it's like woke is like a
friendly word people like that's not
harsh enough president Trump is right
he's like it is sick evil and demonic
and we need to call it out
yeah yep it is demonic and speaking of
which and actually tying this back to
something you mentioned earlier Tim
about elad and the the research that he
was doing in the journalism the good
work he did publishing that video
um and it was a video of course where
people were marching in the treats in
the streets at a pride parade saying
we're coming for your children we're
coming for your children
um NBC tried doing damage control on
this by tweeting the coming for your
children chant has been used for years
at Pride events according to longtime
March attendees in gay rights activist
he said it's one of many provocative
Expressions used to regain control of
slurs
two paragraphs deny the chant even
happened and they said it was just one
guy and we don't even know if he was
lgbtq so it was more than one guy
they're playing drums to it and they're
all shouting it there's a in the video a
girl goes we're we're coming for your
when she says children she winces and
looks aside like even she's having a
hard time saying it out loud but she's
just part of the cult part of that group
and so she goes along she keeps marching
and it's just you know we're at a stage
where NPC really thought they were doing
damage control by saying oh but they've
been saying that forever
yeah
crazy that makes it so much worse this
is the apocalypse well yeah I wonder
another another prediction for Chris to
the Christian right man that's all it's
uh
come November the peak of the torrids I
love it are they going to cause a tidal
shift or something and the oceans are
going to Bubble Up and just sweep maybe
it would happen in the great flood was
it was a strong gravitational pull that
created a large tide that rolls over the
whole planet at once before going back
down have you seen that old simulation
of what it was like when the moon was
closer to the Earth it's that's what
happened it wasn't the moon used to be
really oblong going around really ovular
around the earth and pulling the water
like I don't know how many thousands of
feet in the air just covering land
masses
uh no we won't flood we'll be okay
where's what was the video how do I find
it
uh I saw it on Twitter and it's just a
simulation a short like 30 or 40 second
simulation uh might be that third video
I'm not sure what that's what's that one
called Mars wet to dry animation and to
be clear if we don't address climate
change it will happen again
what was the story in the Bible during
the apocalypse what happens exactly in
the you want me to break down the whole
the whole book give me a three minute
elevator pitch because we're going to
Super chats
um you want like I guess
it's a story where Saint John is writing
Visions about the end of the world and
the different things that he saw taking
place in the The Vision that he saw
basically okay so the reigning
notoriously difficult no the reigning
frogs that's from uh that's from Exodus
I see yeah okay so this is all from
John's Visions yeah so so
there's a number of things it's a
notoriously difficult read
um but yeah there's a number of
different prophecies laid out uh talks
about the dragon sweeping um a third of
the stars from Heaven the the Antichrist
it's there's a lot I call it the
apocalypse because it's that's what
Catholics call it actually instead of
Revelation the the Greeks the word in
Greek means Revelation or disclosure it
means the same thing and ultimately with
the internet was this the video
That's it man that's one of them yeah
this is just how the moon affects gonna
happen again it's gonna happen and when
it was close man
maybe it's not the exact one I've seen
but just imagine if like the water gets
pulled 50 feet above sea level by some
high gravitational force you could
easily get a great flood yeah we're
we're in a this Earth is in insanely
vulnerable things are happening very
slowly cosmologically but
we're lucky that's the eat like it's
kind of it's kind of scary how simple it
is we know the gravitational force will
have this effect on water if some large
body were to pass by close enough and
could could cause I mean I doubt it
because it would have to be as big as
like the moon and be super close
but you know the biggest fear is a melt
a large gel like from some sort of
external heat but since most of the
water the ice is already melted uh from
the last flood we're not really in any
kind of danger of another giant flood I
don't think although what happens is
when the ice is removed so like if the
ice caps were to instantly melt not only
is there a huge flux of water now onto
the Earth's surface but the land that
the ice was on top of that's being
compressed down now goes pops up and
when the land pops up Earth elsewhere
sucks down so that's why they say
Atlanta sunk into the ocean the the land
mass not only to all the water melt but
as North America Rose you know Western
Europe sunk and uh I don't know if
there's enough ice on Earth to produce
that that phenomena at the moment
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time